[Music]
okay get started thank you all for
coming
talk a little bit about Doc Edgerton
today show you a lot of great
photographs I'm tell you lit the end a
little bit about the Edgerton Center and
a little bit about the Edgerton archive
project a couple of special guests here
today Marty Klein up there who worked
with Doc over many many years Ellen I
did Ellen law make it I don't see Ellen
Doc's granddaughter and maybe a couple
of her kids may show up and Paul pin
field or geo to Paul
okay there he is I'll tell I'll tell a
story or two about Paul and and I okay
and Sam Raymond who also worked with doc
I think well we should show up here
pretty quick so let's get rolling
because I've got lots of great pictures
to show you and a little bit history to
tell you about so doctors born in 1903
and the family moved to Washington DC
but you know by the time he was five or
six years old they'd moved back to
Aurora Nebraska so he born in the year
the Wright brothers first flew but he
and one of the things that he said one
of his earliest childhood memories was
seeing the Wright brothers fly in 1909
so I'm gonna give you just a little bit
of chronology when he was living in
Aurora got introduced to photography
from an uncle who is a portrait
photographer as he grew up got into high
school he started working for Nebraska
Power and Light in work summers there
and I think when he was also in college
he attended the University of Nebraska
which is where he got his bachelor's
degree in electrical engineering and
then took a job for a year at General
Electric in Schenectady now I don't have
any photographs of doc from these really
early years and the reason is there's
probably something like 12,000
photographs of DOC and students and
people at the MIT Museum uncatted
unindexed I didn't have time to go dig
through them to find some good
photographs I know they exist so we'll
come back to this theme in a little bit
here is a dot picture of DOC though in
his 20s and in those early years at MIT
he earned a master's degree in 1927
became an instructor in 28 and herb
Grier and Ken garmisch house and were
early students of his he married Esther
1928 and had three children and bob is
the only one still living today the
youngest and he comes to our strobe lab
short course frequently every June so
Doc's early work was on synchronous
electric motors and the this is where he
started using synchronous strobes to
study the motion of motors
got his PA it's doctor science
Electrical Engineering 1932 became
assistant professor in the same year and
at that time started turning his camera
and this then the flash on everyday
things he was I've heard him say that
one of the first things he ever took a
flash picture of other than electric
motor was turning the flash on a faucet
just taking a picture of water and he
took pictures of water all through his
life he was really fascinated by drop
droplets and interesting things in water
this is a very very this is a really
early picture but then he rapidly moved
on to lots of other interesting things
the Harvard football coach 1934 I really
liked this picture because the you can
see in it
how it was triggered see this wire just
a piece of wire and as the ball moves
into it it closes the circuit and pops
the flash and I like the little puffs of
dust you can see coming off the football
when it gets kicked tennis balls
cockfights
this would this was new to me I hadn't
seen this one until I started searching
through pictures early bullet photograph
a little fuzzy this is before what I
call the micro flash which is a air-gap
spark source of light that's less than a
microsecond which is perfected later on
so in the early 30s he begins his
partnership with Kent dermis housing
dermis housing does a lot of experiments
developing improved flash tubes 1933
applies for his first patent is not
granted until 1949 there was a evidently
there was some just a considerable
patent discussion over what what was and
what wasn't original dock was not the
inventor of the strobe one of the
inventors of photography William Henry
Fox Talbot took a strobe photograph in
1859 was an air-gap spark
but not really improve the electrical
control and of course the lighting xenon
flash tubes and those kinds of things in
1935 he licensed the general radio the
first strobe attack and they began
making those they people could began to
see his photographs and first ones were
in an exhibition in the Royal
Photographic Society as early as 1933
and he started doing quite a bit of
consulting in these years turning the
camera and strobe on a variety of
machines and manufacturing processes so
this is just a setup looking at the
cutting tool on a milling machine this
photograph was taken in the ocean
engineering departments water tunnel
which is still existent is in use today
so this is a marine propeller and the
streaks that you can see those are
cavitation bubbles coming off the tip
thread coming off a real high speed
bobbin and this is a hard picture to
understand you are looking up at the
underside of a dye and droplets of lead
are coming out through hundreds of
little holes this is the dye in a
shot-tower this is how you make LED bb's
and they fall and freeze before they hit
the ground so that going moving on into
the late later 30s doc develops the
multi flash starts taking pictures of
lots of animals and other sporting
events and high speed movies so in 1937
what's called the Coronet photograph is
part of the first-ever
photographic exhibition at the Museum of
Modern Art in New York before 1937 I
guess photographs weren't considered art
they made a important change in some
people's mind at that point but became
the one up doc Doc's probably signature
photograph if I forget to say I we but
we have reprinted a bunch of the red the
color ones of that
which you can pick up on the way out so
this is 1936 stock learned that mrs.
Lawrence Webster had the hummingbirds
would just eat out of her hand and so we
went up to New Hampshire to take
pictures of hummingbirds so first stop
action photographs that really froze
hummingbirds in flight that had ever
been taken 50 60 beats per minute this
one you can even see his tongue sticking
out and this is a page from Doc's lab
books there's 8,000 pages of Edgerton
notebooks and they're really an MIT
treasure
they have incredible information in them
this is July 8 1936 my mother and father
were here from July 3rd to today my
sister Marilyn
Mary Ellen our two boys came also dad
and I spent Monday July 6th at the
Acushnet company taking golf pictures
and then the rest of the page is about
mrs. Webster and hummingbirds I would
like to get all of those pages up where
any one of you could log on to the web
and and search by topic and be able to
associate a time and date in place with
Edwin pictures so here's one of those
golf pictures from those days and here's
a page out of the notebook just
wonderful sketches you can tell exactly
what was done this is photographs of
Golf Club for American Fork and whole
company I mean they let anybody make
golf clubs in those days frequency 100
frames per second exposure time set by
hand and shutter for a 5 by 7 camera but
just wonderful diagrams you know exactly
what he was doing and you know this
period of time the late 30s developed a
multi flash unit so this welcome Sam
this this is a single negative taken
with a repeating flash flashing at a
hundred times a second so you can you
know plot out velocity
and you can see the ball coming off the
club doc started taking pictures over at
Boston Garden to do that he had to make
bigger high more powerful strobes and
hung them from the catwalk and the beams
over the garden and this is a rodeo they
actually had inside the Boston Garden in
the late in the late 30s doc went to
Kodak and tried to convince them to
produce strobes and they did a little
market analysis and decided they could
make about 50 a year and they said it's
just never going to be very important
doctor and they declined to do it so he
set out to change to create the demand
that became the modern flash industry
and one of the ways he did that is by
building portable strobe units that he
loaned to sports photographers and this
photograph in 1940 is the first strobe
photograph that went out on AP wire
photo and that began that began to
create demand that and we know what
happened after that and there were lots
of this this is a photograph 1940 taken
prize-winning photo by Jocasta New York
Daily News this is right out of Doc's
non-web book Joe Louis or Torah go to a
rematch 1940 in also 1940 MGM won an
Academy Award for a short done with
Edgerton using of high speed movies this
one's making scrambled eggs with your
house fan
then then along comes world world war
two and doc becomes involved in using
high-intensity strobe developing
high-intensity strobes for night
reconnaissance photography fellow who
came and recruited doc to this business
was a major Goddard of the Army Air
Corps and he'd been working for years on
flash bomb with night photography and he
wanted to know if doc could make it work
with electronic flash whit has huge
advantages so these are some photographs
taken in Britain in 1944 this is
installing flash tubes in a 26 s and a
20s for night reconnaissance photography
the there's a whole series of them made
from the d1 to the d5 they varied from
5000 watt seconds to almost 50,000 watt
seconds there's one of the planes and in
the evening getting ready to go off for
a test run
and he didn't send them to just any
whole place for test runs
he sent the pilots off on the first test
runs whenever they were training there
in Britain they've take photographs of
Stonehenge so this is a night
reconnaissance photograph of Stonehenge
1944 1,500 feet and this is one of my
favorite Edgerton pictures doc knew when
the photograph was going to be taken he
was on the ground put a camera on a
fence post opened the shutter and this
is a nighttime photograph of stonehenge
with illumination from a night
reconnaissance photo plane okay so this
is the matching photograph to that
rather hard picture to reproduce
so that photography had crucial role in
d-day there were pictures take their
thousand vCloud cover a ceiling the
night of June 6th flash bomb photography
wouldn't have worked went in under the
clouds this is a really important rail
and road junction being Normandy German
activity was absolutely quiet that night
they had no idea that the invasion was
about to begin this is that they look at
the bottom here 15 June 1944 and this is
another target photographing in be in
France showing fires burning and so
forth so post-war will move on formation
of EG&G better bullet photography
National Geographic and color so in 1947
doc and the dermis housing in greer
formed EG&G they had been working
together off and on all through the war
Atomic Energy Commission came to him
wanted them to build triggering circuits
for a nuclear weapons test and do and
they moved and on moved on as well to
photography so II GG was formed and they
started taking pictures of for example
like this atmospheric this is on the top
of the tower atomic bomb in this case
they had to develop magneto-optic
shutter the rapid Roenick camera and
those all came out of this era some of
that equipment is in the you can see at
the MIT Museum
Charlie Wyckoff worked on that around
that camera some of you remember him the
micro flash came along in those ears the
micro flash is this air gap spark 1/3
microsecond exposure and you can really
take nice stop-action photographs of
things like bullets it's one of my
favorite bullet pictures the bullet is
right here but this is this is a shows
you doc had this fantastic sense of
composition you know it's a single flash
it's a single instant in time but you
get the whole feeling for how
of how a balloon breaks cuz he was
clever and put three in a row and you
get the whole sequence so that's a 30
caliber bullet twice the speed of sound
black and white and later was the one we
had color film the same picture taking
with color that bullet moves you know
just a few thousandths of an inch in the
course in the duration of that of the
photograph so the way if any of you
don't know how bullet pictures are taken
you turn all the lights off in the room
you open the shutter on the camera you
shoot the gun and the shock wave from
the bullet hits a microphone and the
microphone trips the flash and if you're
standing in the room and you know and
you're looking right at the playing card
get your eyes wide open and it's
completely black Bullock the gun goes
the flash goes off and you can see the
bullet with your eye just you see it
there just sitting there if you're I
just retains the image and it's
interesting how the eye works but it
that one microsecond of light lasts
several milliseconds in your eye and
your brain says hey that's pretty cool
yeah so the first Doc's first article in
National Geographic was 1947 it was
about hummingbirds there was another one
I think in 1951 and a whole series of
geographic articles many of them about
underwater exploration Crawford
greenwalt was the president of DuPont
and hummingbirds were his hobby and he
came to doc to have him learn how to use
flash and built and he built green
Walt's first unit he green what went on
to take publish his own book of
hummingbird photographs but individually
glued in color photographs of birds from
all over the world absolutely
spectacular rare book bats great
photographs including fishing bats I
don't have that picture I have to find
that one and then of course the modern
signature photograph the melt drop
so the 50s to the 70s this is when
marina archeology and underwater work
really became important and in the I was
just looking at some of the listing of
publications so he first met Cousteau
and about 53 and as the story goes the
geographic hooked them up and told him
that Cousteau and I'll send him up and
so there is a photograph I've seen of
Cousteau swimming in the MIT alumni pool
with with dr. underwater flash and
camera and from then on he went on
several two expeditions with Cousteau
and of which you can many of them if you
go back and watch those old Cousteau
specials on TV you the several of them
the doc was involved in then he also did
MIT you did something like Claire how
many where's Claire how many different
archaeological expeditions they either
dot contributed to when or something
like eighty right and the doc had a
profound effect on marine archaeology he
introduced essentially the marine
archaeology community to the use of
sonar for a variety of purposes and it
really revolutionized the way underwater
archaeology was done I'll show you a
little bit of that and Claire Cal
Kanye's here is written is researched a
lot of materials at the MIT Museum and
written papers on docks marine
archaeology so this is so the early I
think the firt docks first use of
underwater sound was to figure out how
far off the bottom camera was because
you put a ping er on the camera and you
lowered it down well each time the ping
er would beep the sound would go
directly to the surface and the sound
would go down to the bottom bounce off
and directly to the surface and the
difference in arrival time told you how
far off the bottom the camera was so
remotely paying out the cable from the
boat you could position the camera
exactly the height off the bottom that
you wanted it to be now five feet off
the bottom is how much difference in
delay a time
- one each way back right two
milliseconds differences five feet in a
millisecond sound travels about five
feet in water so this is one of the next
uses was doc learned that hey some of
the sound is penetrating the bottom and
you can see things beneath the bottom
and this is one of the so the boomer was
born and this was one of the things we
should really use widely and under in
marine archaeology because you get to
find things underneath it underneath
some kinds of bottoms others didn't do
so well and this is one of Doc's
favorite practice targets so Sumner and
Callahan tunnels so you take the boomer
out in the Boston Harbor and go back and
forth searching for the tunnels and
that's these two dome shapes that you
can see in here are the two tunnels
underneath the bottom so this is water
the boats up there this is the bottom
and then underneath the bottom that's
where the tunnels are sitting there's
Marty Klein who's with us today and
Marty and doc developed the first
commercial toadfish narrow beam side
scan sonar at EG&G in 1966 is that about
right party okay then you went when did
you go on to form klein side scan okay
and then you were when you sold it you
sold the company 20 years later
something like that so I'm already got
it yep
so Marty got his start doing sonar with
with doc and made a made a life's work
out of it this is an image that I saw
doc in in in very this very image many
many times he was fond of going right
out here in the Charles River throwing
on a side-scan sonar fish over the side
and going out and testing things before
heading off on a project to
who-knows-where neat book on sonar
images
so if Paul Gray were here he has some
funny stories about these but these are
16-inch naval shells and they were they
would they were sitting out on a pallet
for a long long time over by building 20
and one day Paul likes to tell the story
that a student complained to him about
having this war material laying around
and so he sent he decided well I'll just
send him to see doc because the reason
these shells were here there's
explosives had taken out of the part of
them you can unscrew a piece in the back
and these naval shells dock use them to
make pressure testing vessels out of
them so if you wanted a camera that
could go down 20,000 feet in the ocean
he put it inside the shell close it up
pressurized it hydraulically and tested
it to 20,000 feet I think I disposed of
the last one of these at MIT we had the
when I was a young professor in the
ocean engineering department that baby
laughs the pressure testing vessel that
had been made out of one of these was
still there in a cart standing upright
with all the apparatus and I gave it to
some folks at Woods Hole so that was the
last that's the last we saw of one of
these here at MIT dr. as I said meant
when he went many times with Cousteau to
on board the Calypso one of the
photographs of those trips
in 1975 they went looking for the
Britannic and so this map here's this is
Greece there's a thens and right down
here is where the Botanic Britannic was
found is where it was sunk on World War
one you notice this is this is a tracing
of a map done on MIT letterhead and this
is the added Ox again out of a notebook
this is a side scan sonar trace going
right dead over the center of the
Britannic Calypso November 15th 1975
latitude longitude depth 1973 the doc
went out with a group looking for this
Civil War ironclad the monitor off of
Cape Hatteras were sunk shortly after it
wasn't long after the famous battle that
was in with the Merrimack but then it
was they were towing it north and gotten
storm and sank and it wasn't
rediscovered until 1973 and the user
side scan trace is showing the showing
the monitor on the bottom so I'm going
to tell you just a little bit of story
about my own involvement with Doc we do
it on time ok I came in 1968 summer in
1968 as a grad student probably saw doc
give a talk got fascinated by 1969 I was
going in the army and while I was in the
Army I bought cameras I built my first
photo lab I learned how to take pictures
and when I came back in 1972 I went to
doc in the spring of 72 and said I
really want to take the strobe project
lab course and of course I was a
graduate student at the time I had lots
of laboratory training Betties and you
know he said well will anybody let
anybody in and so he let me in and we
took the strobe project lab course and
just had a ball and that summer I
learned that he needed a teaching
assistant for the next year and I hadn't
yet found a PhD thesis in ocean
engineering that I was happy with and so
doc hired me as his teaching assistant
for the year which gave me time to
develop a really true
ocean engineering Doctorow's subject and
it gave me a chance to do what i'm going
to tell you about docks as when I came
in September doc said why don't you do a
project you know in addition to being
the TA I want you to do a project nice
I've never done colors larren
photography and so once you give it a
try
so I I went to the library and found out
that she colors Lehren is used a lot in
supersonic wind tunnels to take pictures
of shockwaves and there were three or
four different techniques described
there and so I read up on them built the
apparatus took the first picture about a
month later and walked into Doc's office
and he had that little 10 power loop I
don't know how many of you remember him
looking at negatives with its loop then
he got his loop out and he says man he's
coming Ben this is a van I don't I think
it's out of focus so then so then I went
back you know I'd built it the best I
could and that's what we got I went back
and found another technique and built it
in a month later bring in the first
picture and he's bad I don't like the
color okay so this went on until January
I was getting a little desperate and I
was reading the ammeter scientist column
in Scientific American and a graduate
student in Tennessee had come up with a
new way of knowing schlieren he didn't
have the high-speed equipment that I had
but he had a new technique and so I
built that and during IEP in 73 he came
into the photograph one very much like
this showed it to Doc and he says man I
think you've got it so that with that we
took lots of pictures of cool things and
I'll tell you a little bit about a
little bit about flare in here this is a
hot air above a candle and you can see
it's kind of blue on one side and yellow
on the other that column of hot air this
type of colors Lehren the color you see
tells you the direction in which light
has been refracted so if you take a cut
through that hot air and draw yourself a
picture so imagine this is light
traveling through that column of hot air
light bends in the direction of
increasing index of refraction so the
that column of hot air acts like a
diverging lenss because the index is
it's temperature is highest in the
center the density is lowest index is
Lois and so index increases as the
temperature decreases so though it acts
like a diverging lenss and now the way
you get a picture out of it is you set
yourself up with two telescope mirrors
ours are about ten inches in diameter an
eight-foot focal length and you put a
light source at the focal point of one
of them and the light then lands on the
mirror and it creates a collimated beam
of parallel light that light lands on
the second mirror and it's focused back
down to an image of that original point
source and you block that light with a
knife edge and you put a camera right
behind the knife edge so now this red
that red ray of light comes along passes
through the hot air above that candle
and is refracted slightly from its path
hits the mirror but now no longer lands
on the knife edge where the original
image was but gets over the knife edge
and into the camera camera is focused
through the mirror onto the plane where
the candle is sitting and the camera
essentially assembles a photograph out
of light that gets over the knife edge
and it's light that is coming appears to
be coming from the location of the
candle so that's how a Silurian system
the simplest explanation in its larren
system and if you do it then with
multiple sources of different colors you
can make it so that if light is
refracted down it looks yellow up it's
blue left and right or red and green and
everything in between at different
angles so this is a 30 caliber bullet
the light is refracted down in the
shockwaves at the top and come out
yellow up blue but you can see there's a
lot of amazing things in a picture like
this these are little mock stems that's
reflected sound because of the density
difference between hot air and cold air
this is wake turbulence
and this was taken with that micro flash
unit but put into the into the system so
doc early on had taken pictures of
remember the cavitation pictures and the
marine propellers well you can see the
tip vortex in a ordinary house fan by
putting in smoke and so what doc did was
smoke I did with mirrors we've got do
this black this is this is one blade at
the house fan and this is an alcohol
lamp that's just hot air you can see it
in the shell air and it's rolled into
the tip vortex and then shed downstream
as a helix when you're standing in front
of an ordinary fan the buffeting you
feel are these he lists are these little
rotating tornadoes coming by you that
have been spun off the tips of the fan
so this is a 30 caliber bullet a
shadowgraph of Doc's passing through a
piece of cardboard the same sling the
same thing in schlieren this picture you
can see a lot of amazing things going on
there's I get my pointer back there's
sound diffraction over that sharp edge
looks like a new point source there's a
reflection obviously here there's little
bits of supersonic cardboard with their
own little shock wave going on this is a
dark shadow graph of a soap bubble with
a 22 caliber bullet going through it you
can see all sorts of amazing detail in
that soap bubble and shockwaves and
there's this similar photograph in
schlieren
where you see a bullet you can see I
don't know if it shows up yeah I can see
it these are reflected sound wave
shockwaves from the skin of the bubble
so a little one of the things that I
most love about doc was the what he did
for lots of people including me help
folks start companies
he gave generously of his time and his
money and his resources and in my case I
had been taking these clarin photographs
and he liked him and he says Kim I want
you to write it up we're going to you're
going to show these photographs at the
11th International Congress and
high-speed photography which was held in
the summer 1973 at Imperial College in
London and so that was a great
opportunity and I and I wrote the paper
and we sent it off and I took slides
along but doc also took about a dozen of
these photographs sent him out to the
photo lab at EG&G new G&G made 16 by 20
enlargements of them mounted them Doc's
sent them ahead to the Congress they
were put up in a gallery outside of the
main hall where we where the talks were
given and so I had this private show at
the this conference where of course he's
a father of modern high speed
photography so I got there you know he
just had to be tucked under his wing and
it's got to go to everything that
Edgerton went to it was really cool well
one of the people who came to that
gallery was the editors nature magazine
and said basically saw the pictures I
got to have that and so my first
published article was in nature magazine
with a color photograph as a grad
student so this is pretty heady
experience and to this oh and you know I
wouldn't be here today if it if it were
not for Doc Edgerton so you know he
helped me in ways I know and I'm sure he
helped me in ways I'll never know
but he helped other people too and that
was one of the motive real motivations
in 1991 dot died too we want to do
something that would be a really
appropriate legacy to Harold Edgerton
and so in in 1990 there was a discussion
was a family and the family trustees at
the Family Foundation and Paul Penfield
and with Paul Gray and people here at
MIT
as to what would be appropriate and we
came up with the idea that we should the
photographs were great and they would be
preserved but the really important
contribution and the reason students
loved Doc was was that he made his lab
in his time available to help them with
things they wanted to accomplish so we
created the Edgerton Center proposed the
Edgerton Center as a place where MIT
students could come and have a place to
work and Doc was fond of saying you know
a student would walk you know I've
always wanted to try something and he'd
say there's a bench there's a soldering
iron it only takes a couple of
microseconds get on with it
and we wanted to have that be the way of
remembering doc by creating the Edgerton
Center so in 1992 we founded the
Edgerton Center and Paul Penn field and
I were did a lot of the heavy lifting to
make that happen Paul was the department
head of electrical engineering and
computer science at the time and docs
lab was the ECS space and you know how
valuable space is at MIT so and he
wanted this to happen
and so did I and and a lot of other
people including Paul Gray and the
family so an endowment the doc heads set
up as a life trust which would support
Esther his wife until she died became
the permanent endowment of the Edgerton
Center in 2001 so today in our mission
when we opened the doors we wanted to
continue to do high-speed photography we
wanted it to be a hands-on Resource
Center for MIT students the way it had
been when doc was there and we wanted it
to continue something else that doc did
and that was to bit make have it be a
window on MIT he was fond of taking
things out and given talks at school
kids but also people came and we even in
those days that were photographs all up
and down the hallway we wanted to do
that and today that still exists in our
k12 programs so just a little bit about
what goes on today at the Edgerton
Center we still do high-speed
photography so here's one of Doc's
making applesauce photographs and this
is a picture from Stroh project lab
which is a subject that I took in that
ring of 1972 we still teach it today
this is a student photograph
colored chalk we support 20-some student
clubs and teams one of them is a group
called the vehicle designed summit two
summers ago some of us now said it'd be
the spring if it's over two years ago
two women students the one that do on
the left and right here in blue
Robin Allen and Anna Jaffe came to me in
about the first of May and said we have
invited 90 students from solar car teams
from around the world to come to MIT
this summer to build energy efficient
vehicles we need a little help
and I said yeah I yeah you mean the
summer of o7 right this is no no they're
arriving June 12th
so we said about making this happen it
took basically the Edgerton Center
served as the bank and when they had an
$80,000 housing bill that summer they
eventually brought 46 students actually
came they spent eight weeks here they
built four different vehicles that were
running by the last day by the by that
fall they had raised two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in cash to make
this thing happen and they're still
going today I mean they're now doing
their annexed design of a vehicle that
they hope can be mass-produced
so one of the vehicles they built was
this one this is a diesel powered
vehicle built from scratch in the ground
up said they bought the engine and
converted it to burn vegetable oil so it
smells a little bit like a McDonald's
but I got to drive this one this was a
lot of fun and a full-length Discovery
movie was Discovery Channel film was
done on the this summer on the kids
project thanks
the little bit we do k12 work we've been
doing for ten years we've been bringing
teachers in their classrooms from
Cambridge and around who come to do
half-day field projects at MIT in in
topics that are coordinated with their
curriculum so these are kids with a ring
of DNA made out of Lego and Doc was fun
too saying the trick to education is to
not let them know they're learning
something Dell it's too late some of our
teams go abroad and work in developing
countries and this is built around a
woman named Amy Smith who's a now Bend
with the Edgerton Center for six or
seven years and in fall of O 4 she won a
MacArthur grant for work this work in
developing countries with our students a
year ago we had teams of students about
30 total students in seven different
developing countries doing charcoal and
water projects irrigation peanut
Schaller's I mean
and this been there just there they're
out in the field right now amy is in
Peru this IEP with one of the teams of
students but there's six or seven other
teams scattered around the world doing
they're doing they're doing their work
just to show you pictures of the fellow
on the mat on the left that guy up there
he was doing solar power using solar
collectors in that's in in Lesotho in
southern Africa Jessica I'm going to
tell you about Amos winter went to
Tanzania and got involved with making
wheelchairs in an NGO that makes that
makes wheelchairs there and Elizabeth
Bashaw is working on a project doing an
early flood warning system in Honduras
and these projects are continuing
they've gotten World Development Bank
money to help carry them on I mean these
are some of the really more successful
projects but what about Jessica just
tell you her story that I'm about done
Jessica and as part of d-lab which is
this January trip went to Zambia and
Southern Africa and worked in that
January of 2005 in this wheelchair
operation and learned about making
wheelchairs she got an idea when she was
there and she came back that spring and
thought about it that she could make a
bicycle drawn ambulance because they had
no ambulance service in that part of the
world so she came she went back in the
summer with a design built the first
prototype and then the next day IEP she
went back by the time she had gone back
they made six more that's that's the
year they are your bike and this
ambulance had built six more had them in
service and were benefitting people a
year later she went back to designed the
tooling so they could fulfill an order
from the World Health Organization for
like fifty or a hundred of these things
so these are these are life-changing
experiences that are happening at the
Edgerton Center and at MIT so I'd like
to think of the doc would be proud of
what we've done with his with his space
and his laboratory and its name and the
resources that he made possible for us
to do what we're doing so I'm going to
end by telling you a little bit about
the Edgerton archive project I went to
the Family Foundation a few months ago
and said I'd like to do the following
project 99% or more Scottie way more of
the doc material is where you and I
can't get at it there are many many
hours of film that are in Cannes at the
MIT Museum there's this 40-plus
laboratory notebooks at the MIT archives
that all the photographs he took of
things like milk drops there are
negatives of them and they have actually
already been positives have been made in
a standard shape but there's 7,000 of
them and they're not cataloged in a way
that you and I could go look them up and
get to them then there's these 12,000
35-millimeter color slides of Doc and
students and you and me and everybody
doing things and they're not cataloged
or indexed and I like to put all of that
into a web-based archive where any one
of us can get to it and in fact so if
Claire goes in there and sees a picture
she has it seen before and says oh I
know where that is that's Greece and
that's 1975 and that's you know Charlie
Maisel or whoever it is and be able to
put that information in so that over
time we build up a the metadata that
supports all of the doc materials so if
you were early when you came in today
at the beginning we played about a ten
minute loop that there are videos that
are taken from Doc's movies so there was
there are something like 60 or 80 film
clips on tech TV today that you can go
see and so that's just the beginning of
this project so when I began there's
this here's a fellow from early days who
I from 19 you know twenty six or seven I
have no idea who he is but I'd love to
find out somebody can write in and tell
us someday so a parting word from Doc
this is doc standing in front of his
notebooks I don't know if I can make
this happen if I can't we'll just stop
and go to questions I'm gonna
earn this down and if I can get a little
video clip to run here this is where it
will end all right I don't want your
updates do your thing
there's a lot of great footage of Doc in
different things the short that was made
in 1940 we have that this is not gonna
cooperate so here we go hey we're
getting closer twice
yeah okay thank you let's kill one of
these enlarge this and play do something
you waste your time time is very
precious
we're wasting it right now I got surgery
at night all right so that's
[Applause]
we've got a little time thanks for
coming people who've got memories that
they have what they did with Doc or
questions you want to ask times years I
think actually my recall is that he was
in fact working on large motors and
that's where that's been what when he
came to MIT he continued that that work
is the closest connection that I know
what's your name and when was this
I built the widest Tesla coil window air
force base Utah
I worked out there for nine years trying
to make koala lightning them never
succeeded that make things look like
Huawei but wasn't the real thing forty
years I've been in this field haven't
succeeded but we should press on anybody
else I have a favorite story from Doc's
time
I think that's right I've heard that
story to us Caiaphas has been as has
worked and published many of Doc's
photographs there are four books of DOC
photographs the first of which was
published in 1939 and the the first
three were all edited by Jim Killian who
is the president of MIT in the late 40s
and early 50s and the the fourth book
was published in 86 right stopping time
87 and guess I'll have to do with
putting the photographs for those
together for those and that's that's a
beautiful book to stopping they are
they're all really neat books the
earliest one I tie finally I want to
copy and didn't have the very earliest
and got it found a signed copy on book
finders and have a collection yeah
because the back good the shell up point
down and it was standing up this way and
that the back end of it unscrewed and so
that's what you were screwing that in
tight so it would the hold pressure is
what I gather was going on I never saw
that one happened that's funny
[Applause]
I didn't know that story you built a
hundred of them benthos built him pardon
oh so what happens they so I needed to
get some morning bird then the
government had made a whole lot of
chills
so race down there brand-new did you I
guess
did you did you make did you make help
so how many more did you actually sell
another hundred you'd sell another
hundred of them this is too loud okay
well I hope a year from now will be
really far into it we're making the
early progress is in the with the film
right now so we're going to do quite a
bit of the film is already on video and
that's what you saw some of at the
beginning today but we're going to take
another 20 hours or so of it and have it
digitized and turned into video so that
those can be up so that's underway and
well wouldn't ya what I showed at the
beginning today were there are about 80
different short clips that we've gotten
up online already that you can see and
so eventually we'll have a lot more
including the annotation is a really
incorrect that's really valuable ok
guess we have to we need to be talking
ok thank you thank you I'm glad you came
Edie
and the pictures that doc did but the
story of Sam like what you did you
stopped by a couple years ago and
remember I videotape you giving me a
story I sit in the docs desk video
footage the stories that you guys tell
are hugely important I mean they're just
wonderful
day in the life stories so if you could
help to contribute not just by it's the
annotation but by you actually
recounting some stories I'd like to see
how we can encourage that whether it's
through a we get together and share
stories and have a boudreaux you know
like we do it so that's a good idea and
it will get the the first things up you
know the low-hanging fruit just get the
images up and then I'm calling it phase
one there's a lot to be done there but
then I'm I'm hoping that this will stir
up alumni interest in folks around and
that we can kind of go into a Phase two
and add a lot of the metadata and
capture some of those stories that'd be
great any other last ones Ellen could I
see you sneak in with some family and
you want it
Ellen Ellen law your Doc's granddaughter
right and you have any others Paul
early
[Music]
so we'll well close I'll tell you one
last one of my favorite stories I
remember of Doc and that was you know
you're you've many have you been on the
receiving end of postcards and I was a
teaching assistant that year in 72 73
and we had a Freshman Seminar and doc
and I were both standing by the door and
the students were filing in and this
young man
stopped in had and he had his girlfriend
with him who was kind of his high school
sweetheart who was visiting and he said
that doc he said would it be all right
if if Mary comes to class today and doc
got this stern look on his face he says
she can't come to my class without a
pass and she bought died right on the
spot and he whips out of postcards and
says here's a pass
so I thank you all it's been great fun
[Applause]
represented not necessarily the same
technology but same attitude and since
that time it's been a wonderful success
so I think of a lot of God to be coast
of the way Kim has preserved this in it
and made the Edgerton Center a real
force that they might be in information
[Applause]